i want to ask you this um
dr chloe
so i was thinking about dating apps and
we've talked about this on the show
before
i was talking to this young guy
this is a few years ago he was like 26
and he was a virgin and hadn't had a
girlfriend
and he was saying that it was basically
impossible and through the conversation
it was interesting basically what he was
saying was that you know all everyone
dates through tinder and other apps and
stuff so he's on there but he can never
get any responses and i was like
interesting i started reading some uh
data from dating websites and it looks
like what may be happening
in colleges
you have
20 year old men and women let's just use
an average age
they're all on tinder the 20 year old
man has no status has no wealth he's in
college so when he reaches out to appear
a 20 year old woman and he says want to
hang out she goes sure what do you have
in mind we can go to the the courtyard
and we can like talk and she's like
that's cool then she swipes right on a
30 year old guy who makes 70 80 000 a
year he's got a got a nice car he's got
his own apartment and he says you want
to hang out to us what do you want to do
and he says we can drive to the lake go
see a movie then come back to my place
i've got drinks and she goes done yeah
even more he doesn't just say you want
to hang out he says would you like to go
have dinner right you know i feel like
from the start he's whining and dining a
little more
so
it feels to me that
dating apps have expanded the dating
pool so massively that young men no
longer have a peer group in which they
can find a mate
and higher status men now get access to
basically every
every available woman
so what we started seeing is this was
reported by the washington post
that i think a third of men under 29
were virgins
and
you know unmarried as well not dating
that that was i think four years ago so
it's probably gone up since then
something is happening i'm wondering if
you uh you know what your thought is on
dating apps and if you would agree yeah
yeah i totally agree with what you said
about the numbers game and you know the
fact that now that 20 year old woman as
well she's going to be this like hot
item you know if she's open to going out
with 30 year old guys right so she it
really shifts the the dating dynamics
and then also you know i've read
something similar about the virginity
rate like amongst you know very young
people and i think it may also have to
do with the proliferation of porn you
know as sheamus was saying i mean to
really get out there and like you know
find somebody it's even for a one-night
stand you know it's it's not easy right
you have to take certain social risks
you have to put yourself out there you
have to deal with rejection you know
there's so many hurdles that you have to
clear and if young men are able to get
their appetites you know pretty much
fully satisfied from the comfort of
their own home for less money and less
effort i can see where they would have
less motivation as well and then as you
said if the dating app dynamics are
making it even harder for them yeah and
i think that's that's absolutely correct
and it's not just that their need is
satisfied in some sense it by virtue of
what it is you only have to think about
yourself in in your own pleasure and not
another human being who you're involved
with and on top of that it's very sad
when you see how the dynamic is played
out because men will point out the fact
that women have all these options on
these
dating apps the reality is most women
want to find one man to be monogamous
with and they're not able to do that
because guess what the guy they're
interested in because he's at the top of
the dominance hierarchy so to speak he's
got a bunch of other women who are into
him and he's messing around with all of
them and he's not going to commit to any
one of them so it's this this this
horrific like sexual hellscape where no
one gets what's going to make them happy
or or it's a revert to a primitive state
where the alpha
just gets all the women yeah we need
everything called genghis
i'm pretty sure what chimps do is like
the chimps all beat the crap out of each
other and the chimp who wins bangs all
the girls all the women you know it's
also interesting too with prides of
lions
when um like uh the the males from a
warring pride come and like defeat the
males of another pride the females of
the defeated pride will immediately go
sleep with the victorious males
not loyal man wow you know but i mean
also sheamus to your point about about
them getting their needs satisfied you
you kind of touched on something there
that i think is important too which is
that young men who are sexually
inexperienced you know virgins they
might think that they're getting their
needs satisfied in the sense that like
that they're seeing porn and they're
having an orgasm check
but like they don't know the pleasure of
like being with a woman and
you know laughing together and and the
the touch and the intimacy and the fun
of it because they haven't experienced
it so they might think that they're
getting satisfied but they don't realize
that they're not really getting it all
yeah
i think a lot of them know and are very
bitter about that i think a lot of them
know that they're not really getting a
full authentic experience and that they
are sort of being cynically exploited by
the people who produce this kind of
hideous stuff and that it's inhibiting
their ability to have real relationships
when you have an orgasm with alone in
your room you're losing a lot of fluid
like there it goes but when you're with
a woman you're introducing the fluid to
them they're introducing the fluid to
you and so you're getting something
you're not just not just a net loss when
you're with someone it's a trade and
that's a very different feeling like um
emotional or like chemical chemical
experience uh correct me if i'm wrong
but i think a better way i think i i
think this may be more accurate there is
like a uh the exchanges in what you
smell that triggers certain you know
blood flow and release of chemicals in
the brain
right yeah yeah there's definitely
things that you smell but i mean it's
also even the the sense of being held
and squeezed and you know just felt and
loved and and kissed and and known i
mean there's just there's a there's an
interpersonal component to sex
but isn't that insane that you should
even have to say that like strips
when men and women smell each other
their blood flow increases their like
blood vessels dilate chemicals get
released
i think it depends on how he smells to
be fair for the woman i think if he
smiles no no no
i was making a joke no no so the point
i'm making is that if the woman is
attracted attracted to the man or if the
man smell like i'm not saying the smell
makes the attraction or the attraction
makes a smell but there is a correlation
between a man smelling good and woman
being attracted to him pheromones it's
there's that famous documentary series
they did the science of sex
where they had a bunch of dudes run on
treadmills took their shirts off and put
them in jars then had women come in and
smell each shirt and write whether it
smelled good or bad and it turns out the
women who said the shirts smelled that
some the women
said some shirts smelled bad they would
be related to that man
yeah that's crazy they said oh this one
smells good they were not related if it
smelled bad they they're like that was
your brother and she's like oh wow
i noticed also you didn't even need to
see him to know it's not a mate for not
a potential mate it would be bad right
it's funny because i've known girls who
like really complain about the way that
their brothers smell yeah right exactly
and then i was reading that they tell
women if they're going to get married to
get off birth control yes because it
negatively impacts their like recep like
sensory reception to the man
and then when they stop taking the birth
control they say stop taking it wait a
few weeks and if your man smells bad you
can't get married i've noticed also
about sexual intercourse is that it
builds confidence and i like the word
confidence because it has the word
confide like you're actually um
confidant con and you're you're
basically interacting with another
person in this like really
primal primally evocative you know
proactive manner and you're able to make
eye contact for instance and it's like
the level of confidence that you get out
of that is not even remotely uh
there in porn it's nothing like that
nothing it's a completely other it's
basically having a friend like a really
good friend oh my gosh i could see where
porn would almost be like the opposite
right because like you know you're
you're sitting there and you're like
either like paying some website or you
know you're like
basically doing something where you're
validating to yourself almost the idea
that that you can't get somebody or
whatever you know so it's almost like
invalidating but it's also it's also it
warps people's minds
the the the the weird
the weird stuff on the internet is so
far outside of the realm of reality it
used to be like a dude would be like i'd
like to be in bed with that woman now
it's a guy being like i would love to
swing from a ceiling fan while bungee
jumping you know like just all the weird
crazy and it really fosters that right
because if you are in the context where
you are married to a woman who you're
having sex with you love this person you
don't want to do anything to her that
would be considered degrading so if
there is some intrusive thought or weird
fantasy you're not going to indulge it
with pornography first of all there's no
one there to check you so there's no one
there to be like that's a weird thing to
want you can literally search whatever
you want and then people just people are
obsessed with novelty and so they search
for more and more deranged things and
when you look at the fact that erectile
dysfunction rates have increased as much
as they have it's almost certainly
attributable to the wide accessibility
of pornographic materials especially to
boys who are still teenagers i think i
think i think jordan peterson talked
about that right like young maybe i'm
wrong but i was reading something where
young men are watching this ridiculous
you know fake reality stuff and then
when it comes to the real world thing
they're like i don't i don't know what
this is exactly but i do want to i don't
want to say look man i think if people
want to be kinky and do stuff in the
bedroom and be whatever they want to be
or whatever i got notion with that
my issue is when people start separating
themselves from reality with weird stuff
that's just like like i said like
swinging from a ceiling fan while
jumping out of a plane and then throwing
the ceiling just like weird that's not
going to happen i mean i guess if you
want if you're rich enough to make that
happen and you want to bang someone
while jumping out of a plane there's a
big difference between two people having
sex where they're not looking at each
other they don't even know each other's
they don't care it's just two bodies
smashing together the girls in pain
because it's like so hard but and then
the situation where it's two people that
are connecting to each other and they
feel each other's bodies they're not
moving to hurt they're not ignoring the
other person while they're just pounding
and it's like but the internet doesn't
know how to to differentiate between
that and so the kids see both and they
don't know what's supposed to be good or
bad and then you get the warping effect
kids shouldn't see it at all there's
another argument the average age now is
11 that kids are born to tim's point
also about the just what we call a need
for an increasing stimulation right so
the first time maybe that you sit down
and look at porn online you're even just
getting some adrenaline from that
because you know you're doing something
taboo and so your body because of the
extra adrenaline will actually sometimes
have a more intense sexual experience
like there have been some studies even
that showed that people who just walked
across a scary bridge that was really
old and rickety that they would rate
people as more attractive than people
who had just walked across a very safe
bridge so when people you know use porn
to a certain degree it's almost like a
drug but then once you've seen the same
stuff a million times it becomes sort of
ho-hum and so then people just need to
keep doing as tim was saying stuff
that's you know even more and more
bizarre to kind of keep up that sort of
a hit and then there's the other factor
which is that these sites make money by
getting you to spend more time on it and
so they'll be popping up uh stuff that
you might never have even thought of but
there you are with your your body
physiology all turned on to the point
where you could look at a baked potato
and think it was sexy right and then and
then you end up with a guy in the
hospital with a broken light bulb in his
ass yeah
were you thinking dude like who's on the
internet so i mean your studies of
psychology what is like a good tactic
for people to maintain that adrenaline
rush with their partner well so i
actually have an article about that um
it's called don't have chemistry with
nice guys here's how to change that um
if anybody wants to um email me through
my website i'll send you a copy of the
blog if you can't find it um but so what
what i suggest people do like this is
it's kind of old-fashioned but like
that's why people go to horror movies on
dates because like it kind of like gets
things going a little bit you know or do
even going to like new places new
restaurants that kind of thing um escape
rooms anything that just gets your blood
going and gets that um kind of
excitement going um will kind of
transfer onto the sex yeah actually i
actually read that um when women are
scared they generate a stronger bond
with the person they're on a date with
correct they need to and so there was uh
i think it was a study about they you
know monitored people on dates and and
they had them walk across a rickety
bridge and the women reported like
higher bonding or satisfaction with
their date when they were walking across
a rickety it's really weird well i mean
trauma bonding right is not not a real
phenomenon i'm curious about this well
it's even just the increase in
adrenaline right so so when you have
more adrenaline going you know your your
heart is beating faster you're getting a
little sweaty um it's it's almost like
the same as being turned on you know and
so you're you're just experiencing all
of your physical sensations more
intensely and also you're you're
blocking out thoughts of anything else
because your mind goes into this tunnel
vision yeah fight or flight yeah but i
think i think even beyond the studies
we've done on this stuff there's there's
like the joke in in tv shows and movies
where the guy stages a mugging to
impress the date
it's like that that we just knew that we
knew that you go on a date with a woman
and then if if the guy defends or he
looks tough it's attractive and then we
do science we're like oh yeah that
actually happens or the girl stages a
damsel in distress moment and you know
the man comes to
are there dietary things that can
improve adrenaline i i don't know about
that i don't know thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you